what if we actually had a conservative
leader of the conservative party what if
we actually had somebody who came out
tomorrow and said you know what
I don't want to have an economy built
around importing cheap migrant labor for
the next 20 years I don't want to have a
country that can't solve the housing
crisis while running net migration at
500 000 and I don't want a country that
is still falling over itself to invest
in London and the graduate class while
ignoring everybody else and I don't want
a country that is increasingly
exposing our children to an experiment
that has no basis in science
that person would be very popular that
person would
lose sw1 in London in two days but out
there in the wider country they would be
incredibly popular because they would be
saying what everybody is basically
thinking which is that this experiment
this liberal Revolution isn't working